Let's learn one last method to help us solve what may look like a quadratic
equation. Let's look at the equation x to the fourth minus 13x squared plus 36
equals 0. This equation is considered to be a pseudo-quadratic equation, or a
false one. It almost appears to be quadratic, but we really have a fourth power
here. Notice too that we have no odd powers of x. We just have x to the fourth,
x squared and then no x term, just a constant here. We can change this equation
into a quadratic equation that we can potentially solve. This part would be
quadratic, since we would have something squared minus another something plus a
constant. Notice how the powers on any variable term would be 2 then 1 and then
0, since there's no variable here. In this first equation, we actually have a
repeated expression here. When we have an expression that's repeated, we can
make a substitution for that expression and replace it so we have a simpler
equation to solve. So what do you think is that repeated expression? What
should we place inside these parentheses?